every moment every beat is mapped out
talking about a month-long process just
for that 15 seconds stranger things is
easily one of the most terrifying shows
on netflix we've seen demogorgons mind
players and now we've got vec now
lurking around waiting for our cape bush
cd to skip have you ever wondered what
the show would look like without the
visual effects bringing these creatures
to life let's get into it okay
special effects
number one
the duffer brothers only knew a few
things for certain about the demogorgon
they wanted him to come from another
dimension and have a human body type the
body type was really important to them
because they wanted to be able to put an
actual person inside the costume for
season one shooting purposes
very quickly we realized okay so
practical isn't always gonna work in
season four however they brought in
animation the first animation pass
that's when you're seeing what looks
almost like just a gray clay rendering
the first pass is really important
because that's when they can hammer out
the details like how long they want him
to roar for example after that they get
to the rendering stage that's where the
fun really starts everything they've
shot all the animation and real-life
stunts get to coexist together it's
really exciting when those shots finally
come together and all the elements
number two
the demogorgon is one thing but the
actual fight scenes require a different
approach a good portion of time the
demogorgon is just a guy in a green suit
sometimes he would have a
tennis ball at the top of his head to
show us how tall the demogorgon was in
the scene where hopper has his major
showdown with the demogorgon the duffer
brothers really wanted to try and do
that entire scene in one shot but
unfortunately because of how dangerous
the stunts were they were not able to do
that we didn't want to be using cg
people on top of a cg so we weren't able
to do it all in one shot they wanted to
protect their stunt team so they did
three big stunt sequences and stitched
them all together would you have been
able to tell
the americans are very tricky
number three
it takes a lot of work an entire team of
people in fact to make vechna look as
horrifying as he did the actor jamie
campbell bauer went through an egregious
eight and a half hour prosthetic
application every time he had to play
vecna one thing they couldn't do with
prosthetics though was remove his nose
on each application day we had a black
nose on jamie with some little white
marking dots so vfx could remove that in
post vfx also added in those creepy
slithering vines coming out of vecna's
back time for you
to join me
number four speaking of vechna his eight
and a half hour prosthetic seems to pay
off because the cast was typically very
frightened whenever they chewed a scene
with him vecna was pretty much fully
practical effects made it easier for me
so i'm not like staring at a man in a
green suit sadie sink also spent a great
deal of her time in a harness rehearsing
for her levitation scene right before
her big showdown in the upside down
there's not a lot that you have to do
because it's genuinely just so scary
number five
one thing you might not know about
steve's journey to watergate was that it
wasn't even shot in a real lake it was
shot in a convention center in atlanta
georgia joe kiri recounts diving into a
40-foot tank specifically built for this
scene getting to do that sort of stuff
is like true
movie magic
number six
the insane shootout that destroyed every
inch of the buyer's home was also shot
in one take sean levy the director of
episode 4 was compelled to do it all in
one shot he said it was the most
challenging and most rewarding scene
he's ever directed the whole challenge
with the oner is it requires perfect
synchronicity considering they only had
one choreography session for this scene
it's fair to say they killed it
everybody needed to do their job at a
high high level of near perfection
it's a doozy
number seven
you know that part when feckness victims
are getting every bone in their body
snapped like a wishbone on thanksgiving
of course how could you forget it's
quite difficult to watch but
surprisingly not that difficult to
achieve with special effects to break
the fingers it's essentially working
with different layers of a moving hand
within adobe after effects for the legs
they utilize a much more practical
approach they need to put their arms
through the pants so they can function
as legs and with the bigger range of
motion of an arm we can now create a
twisting breaking movement who's vector
[Music]
an undead creature of great power
number eight
the unique thing about stranger things
is how they blend practical effects like
makeup and prosthetics with vfx in every
scene with vfx they also heavily rely on
the makeup team as we stated earlier
jamie campbell bower worked very closely
with the makeup team so close that he
had his own team of people applying lube
onto his entire body our last 10-15
minutes should be the four of us
literally getting this product all over
him to make him look really glossy
number nine
we're all familiar with eleven's iconic
nosebleed but have you ever wondered how
they get the blood to flow at the right
time at first corn syrup a lot of it the
only time millie would get to call
action on set was when she felt it
dripping from her nose you know my nose
is running with blood so i'm like okay
are we ready it's coming three two
right because that didn't always go
according to plan they ended up using
cgi blood for those scenes in later
seasons it's fun to film but also really
stressful
number 10
the character of victor had a brutal
disfiguring after his encounter with
vecna in reality we can thank the
brilliant prosthetic work of barry dower
for victor's disturbing look the
sculpture of victor creel's appliance
which you can see the difference in tone
where the appliance finishes just prior
to robert's hairline the two-hour
process was so bad for the team because
they were able to reference actual scars
as opposed to something that is
completely fictional i suppose
all evil
must have
a home
number 11
11 is me like 11 is just who i am now it
doesn't take very long for the cast to
transform into their characters but
millie's transformation into 11 is a
little more involved it takes about an
hour to do my old wig my makeup isn't
that crazy at all so judging by this
math you could create at least eight
elevens in the time it takes to create
one bechnot jaime campbell bower we do
not envy you underneath all that molding
clay
number 12
in stranger things the upside down is
just as important as any other character
in the show so how exactly do they
create it a recurring theme we've seen
with the duffer brothers is that they
prefer to do things as practical as they
can we realized that in fact the vision
that the brothers had
was more extensive than one can always
do practically when it comes to creating
all of the upside down creatures they
had to call on a team of cgi experts it
starts usually with a sculpture so we
digitally sculpt things so with a
mixture of practical components and a
hard-working visual effects team they
were able to create this stunning world
just beneath our own should we recreate
the scene where you picked me up
although i have gotten a bit bigger now
you are a bit bigger we're running up
that hill and discovering all sorts of
fun behind the scenes moments from
season 4 of stranger things which scene
was completely ruined by someone missing
their entrance let's enter the upside
down and find out number one
part of what makes vechna so compelling
is his creepy look you may be surprised
to learn that the stranger things team
created becna almost entirely with
practical effects one of the main goals
of prosthetics designer barry gower was
to create the character as close to 100
as possible actor jamie campbell power
had to endure a grueling prosthetic
application process they glued different
pieces of prosthetics directly to
campbell's skin how many pieces about
2425
the reason was it gave cambo more
movement than a rubber suit would and it
looked more natural the downsides though
aren't pretty it took about seven hours
to apply everything and it was very hot
to wear so campbell would spend time in
an air-conditioned tent in between takes
to give him a slimy gross look he was
painted with glossy silicone and would
sometimes be coated with jelly another
unique part about beckner's character is
his eerie void the broken house was a
real set they built on a blue screen
with giant red lights shining down put
it all together and you get some
seriously badass scenes
number two
eleven's shaved head back in season one
is iconic but millie bobby brown wasn't
looking to actually shave her head again
for the role this time around they went
with a wig for all of the flashback
scenes with 11. to get the wig on and
looking proper it took about an hour i
think millie is one of the longest
getting ready just because of her wigs
number three
billy is back well at least in a creepy
hallucination kind of way daker
montgomery was super excited to be able
to reprise his role as billy hargrove as
he showed when he was getting his gnarly
prosthetics applied even though he was
only in one scene it was a massive
challenge to pull off due to kovitz
restrictions the solution was to have
him film all of his scenes separately in
australia while director sean levy
directed him over a video call that
sequence in episode 4 was one of the
biggest rubik's cube challenges of my
directing career this took place an
entire year after they had already
filmed sadie's sink scenes yet you would
be none the wiser watching the scene as
they blended the two actors performances
seamlessly
number four
the epic fight scene in episode 4
showcased how well the casting crew can
do action it was one long take so
everyone had to be on their a game one
take was going particularly well and
seemed like it was going to be the
perfect run however when they got to the
very end one of the stunt guys missed
his q leaving everyone on set completely
perplexed after about a five second
delay the guy came barging in to do his
thing and thought he had nailed it and
then he got up and he was like i think
that went well if that was a bit by the
stunt guy kind of weird they eventually
got the scene done on their fifth take
number five
who would have guessed being a character
on stranger things would mean you have
to take golf lessons that's exactly what
charlie heaton and eduardo franco had to
do to prepare for one of their scenes
the scene has them hitting golf balls
off a ridge down into a junk pit so they
needed to have proper golf form they
went to a fancy country club and the
wardrobe department gave them very yuppy
golfing golfing outfits to go which
eduardo absolutely hated it's actually
super difficult just hitting it was so
hard like there's so much technique
luckily for them their shots didn't have
to be perfect as cgi was used for some
of them that shot's definitely cgi
there's no way eduardo hit that
number six
let's go to the roller rink millie bobby
brown and noah schnapp had a ton of fun
filming their rinko mania scenes they
filmed these scenes at the real roller
king location in albuquerque new mexico
in their down time milly would place
some music over the speakers and they
would go skating around the rink in one
behind the scenes blooper milly and noah
ran headlong into each other both
falling to the ground in laughter
honestly this week at the roller rink
has been a blast
number seven
it seems as if there is a lot of down
time on set during one of these times
milli and noah competed in the fruit by
the foot challenge wherein they had to
eat the gummy snack without using their
hands millie took the victory and
defended her title against jimmy fallon
when she challenged him
number eight
noah schnapp is known to be a big
jokester on set so when the opportunity
arose for millie to pull a practical
joke on him she didn't hesitate during
their last day of filming millie set up
a water balloon ambush with the help of
the crew at 4 am she called noah to get
him back to set and even fake cried to
ensure he would be lured into her trap
when he arrived he was greeted with a
barrage of water balloons according to
millie the assault lasted for a whopping
15 minutes
number nine
while filming a scene for the very last
episode of season 4 caleb mclaughlin had
to make a noise but it sounded sort of
odd it was supposed to be a panic scene
but the noise kept making his co-star
mason dye laugh caleb said it became a
running joke between the two which we
can only assume means the two would make
the goat-like noises around set
number 10
the scene of the kids in the pizza band
following eleven's roller skate
smackdown of angela is supposed to be a
sad and tense moment however jonathan
and argyle's antics in the front seat
had the kids cracking up charlie heaton
and eduardo franco improvised their blip
blip blip banter and every time they did
it the three in the back of the van
couldn't help but laugh
number
when you're shooting a production as
large as stranger things you don't have
much time to sleep or eat that formula
made for a shockingly hilarious moment
during a night shoot in the middle of
the woods sadie sink decided to take a
nap when she woke up around 5 30 am she
was greeted by caleb and gaitin chowing
down on full-size quesadillas in
complete silence as they stared straight
ahead sadie was bewildered by the moment
and couldn't get over the absurdity of
it all i don't know why
that just like i don't know it put me
over there
i was like i'm going back to sleep it
may have been an odd moment for her but
caleb stood by his decision it was
really good
number 12.
it can get very hot when filming
outdoors in the summer heat so the cast
was really happy one day when ice pops
were brought to set for them to enjoy
the only problem was the ants not to
worry though because gaitin had a genius
solution cause you had this idea we're
like well what if we made a trail of
popsicle juice
did it work
not exactly the crew just ended up using
ant spray and yet those popsicles were
totally worth it it was kind of a rough
day i remember but the ice pops made it
like
number 13
one of finn wolfhard's favorite memories
from shooting this season was a simple
one he was just happy to be together
with everyone the gang was very split up
in the previous season so when they were
mostly together right from the get-go it
was nice just being together was really
nice you savor those moments
number 14 this season of stranger things
was mostly filmed in new mexico and
lithuania the new mexico location was
used to recreate southern california and
the cast and crew loved it also being in
new mexico has been like so fun for me
it sounds like everyone had a great time
on set and that it was an experience
they will never forget and we've had a
blast and it's been the best proof it
sounds like everyone had a wonderful
experience working on season 4 of
stranger things it's a long car ride
back from where we were in california
now we're in utah stranger things never
disappoints when it comes to 80s
nostalgia so we're taking a look behind
the scenes to find out just how they
turned back time and gave us gnarly sets
like the wrinkle mania and surfer boy
pizza
number one the best sets are the ones
you can goof around on honestly this
week at the roller rink has been a blast
the wrinkle mania was shot in the roller
king in albuquerque new mexico every day
at lunch millie connects our phone and
we just skate around the ring does
anyone else think those safety mats just
look kind of uncomfortable number two
we're not talking about eleven's water
tank not this time no we're talking
about steve's dive to the bottom of love
lake to watergate it was in a big
convention center in atlanta by the
airport it was shot in a giant tank how
big do you think it was guys it went
roughly 40 feet around and 16 feet down
getting to do that sort of stuff is like
true
movie magic originally joe was told he'd
have to be a swimmer there was supposed
to be a whole arc in season one and he
was supposed to show up in a speedo so
he was like oh shoot i have to get in
shape then they cut it this swimming
plotline made its return for season four
he could already swim before though
number three ah yes the only thing worse
than prison is snow prison the scenes
set in russia were actually filmed in
lithuania in the same city used to film
chernobyl we shot in a
real prison the prison only closed in
2019 after running for over a century
for a lot of it i'm running shoeless
through the snows of lithuania david
harbour admitted it was very difficult
this year for me it was a lot of cold
weather it was barefoot in the snow in
lithuania 20 feet below and i wasn't
eating a lot of food because i was very
emaciated this season and so it was a
brutal season on me physically and
emotionally so i found my inner wolf my
inner russian bear
while it was tough harbor found he
really loves doing work like this
because he feels it provides the
audience with a rich experience allows
them catharsis and says he is very happy
to suffer in that way and before we hop
on over to the video store the plane
crash was absolutely ridiculous and
that's exactly what the film crew was
going for when it does an immediate nose
dive upon the engine being turned off
that's actually an homage to 80s movies
planes will glide slowly to the ground
without power
number four as abandoned as a
blockbuster the video store is a very
clear and blatant expression of
everything that inspires the show the
video store was shot both interior and
exterior after they abandoned the
location the only thing remaining was
their store hours unfortunately those
don't seem to be very accurate they
should just stay closed the palace
arcade from the previous season is right
beside the video store and in a previous
life in the right side up aka our world
the whole thing was a laundry mat number
five into the rabbit hole we go we can't
say we're surprised this was filmed in
studio it would be rather ridiculous to
scout out a location for it of course
all of the vines in vekna's lair were
added in post got a little scraped up
but it was really really fun number six
they just can't quite shake this place
huh hawkins lab is back again for season
four and the rainbow room is all decked
out with padding we imagine to protect
all the children who are being thrown
against walls in these scenes emory
university's brier cliff campus in
atlanta georgia was used for the lab
number seven that feel when you graduate
middle school but your high school is no
different hawkins high and middle school
used the same abandoned school property
while this may seem like a lazy choice
architects of a similar period often
build schools similar shapes and designs
stranger things is not strapped for cash
so this seems more like an aesthetic
choice than a lazy one for season four
they painted the track and we said
goodbye to the middle school now that
our youngest characters have entered
grade nine and it looks like the
basketball players were having a ton of
fun on set making up handshakes and
playing ball on their time off number
eight time to drive 3 000 miles to find
a hacker they were hanging out in utah
at susie's house actually we're in
atlanta but we don't say that we're not
exactly sure of the address other than
the street number saying 308 and susie's
bedroom was filmed on a sound stage a
mix of practical staging and green
screen was used probably because that
front door is facing a road and they
only wanted trees probably
number nine et phone home to hawkins
filming for the fictional california
location lenora hills actually took
place in new mexico that was millie's
favorite location to shoot in the
interior of the buyer's home was shot on
a soundstage the exterior was filmed in
the shadow hills area in albuquerque
moving the family to california was in
honor of e.t lenora high was also shot
at el dorado high school in albuquerque
as well number 10 we genuinely didn't
think this one was built from scratch
yes it's true the demogorgon pit was not
a found location it serves the function
of sort of this gladiatorial arena their
challenge was to justify a space with
oversized dimensions it's all bleak
rusted metal with ancient brick and
plaster walls number 11. once you strip
away the movie magic the krill house is
almost pretty the krill house is called
the claremont house in real life it is
far less spooky when it isn't boarded up
and is almost elegant at one point it
was a bed and breakfast for 16 years but
now it is privately owned the house was
built in 1882 and remains in good
condition the upside down version of the
krill house is on the other hand all
fragmented pieces and not cgi number 12
do you think they knew ahead of time
this location would come back they
filmed at stone mountain cemetery in
stone mountain georgia it's the same
cemetery they used for barb's funeral in
season 2. prep for the cemetery took a
lot more work than it may seem just
expect that when you've got stunts
involved that requires rigs and sadie
stunt was practiced off location before
they moved on in number 13 we love the
way they've been building up the world
in subtle ways the trailer park was
briefly mentioned in season two when
nancy and jonathan said it was a good
place to meet with barb's mother but
didn't make a real appearance until this
season forest hills was filmed at a real
trailer park in griffin georgia number
14. anybody remember that phone number
while the chain may not be real walmart
did partner with stranger things for
some frozen pizzas did you manage to
snag your own for binge watching the
shots were filmed in los lunas new
mexico and they also had multiple surfer
boy pizza vans on site too but the first
van they went with just did not do the
trick while it looked really cool it
just didn't have the space they needed
on the inside so they switched to a vw
we shot like a stoner
thriller
comedy kind of number 15 not an ideal
way to spend a day but anything for the
shot we suppose pennhurst mental
hospital is located in atlanta and shot
in georgia while the building was closed
in 1987 it was reopened as a halloween
attraction both the interior and
exterior of this scene were filmed on
location other than victor kriel's sell
scene which was filmed in studio it was
like
so fun and like different we can always
count on stranger things to deliver the
best 1980 sets even benny's burgers made
a small appearance but seeing it all
boarded up just breaks our little hearts
not only does max get trapped in vecna's
mind layer but sadie sings experience
filming the scene really wasn't all that
different we'll be going through the
effects the set the intense stunts and
bloody water sadie had to carefully wade
through as well as the emotional aspects
behind choosing the song running up that
hill there were a lot of terrifying
moments scrapes bruises and some stellar
acting involved in the making of this
iconic scene max
max
max
[Music]
you're not
really here
we know by now that the visual effects
team on stranger things works overtime
in order to give us incredible scenes
like this now vechna when he told max he
was really there he definitely wasn't
lying the actor jamie campbell bauer
spent over six hours a day in the makeup
chair to look that good if it was like a
7 a.m crew call
he would have to come in at
1am what the morning before while they
put the makeup on him as vechna and
apparently jamie never complained about
it he was super patient throughout the
entire process when shooting the
mind-layer scene that was the first time
sadie sink had seen jaime in his vecna
prosthetics to say she was scared is
definitely an understatement part of the
reason why stranger things look so
incredible is that they try to use as
many practical effects and set pieces as
they can instead of solely relying on
cgi we always try to combine real art
department constructed environments with
these digital elements the director sean
levy wanted to make the actor's job as
easy as possible the more you can
practically build the more you're
helping your actor do their job in the
shot where max sees chrissy's body
mounted up on a pillar sadie actually
had a real-life dummy to react to they
altered the way it looked with special
effects but ultimately it was just a
dummy covered in glycerin chrissy's dead
body didn't look as good as it looks in
the finished product
it's hard not to be impressed with the
stranger things production team they
love to build as many practical pieces
as they can this set is no different set
was pretty impressive it was like a
full-on platform that was built on a
sound stage the only part of the set
they couldn't create in a practical way
was the sky it was surprisingly just a
blue screen but obviously you would
never know after the visual effects team
takes over otherwise all of the major
set pieces like the pillars and the
rocky ground were built by the art
department she was standing in a real
rocky bloody kind of pan sadie had to be
really careful walking through it
because it was insanely slippery she
definitely left with a few scrapes and
bruises but we'll get into that in a
little bit one really important piece of
this set was the winding staircase which
of course was a totally real practical
set piece it played a big role in
regards to the camera work and framing
of the scene it allowed me to frame the
expanse of the mind layer and to also do
shots behind that staircase sean levy
finds it helpful to have a practical
element like the staircase in the
foreground when figuring out how to
frame a shot before moving on we have to
give a shout out to kate bush max
wouldn't have made it through this
daunting set without her fun fact the
duffer brothers and their music
supervisor nora both separately chose
running up that hill to be max's escape
song they thought the lyrics really rang
true to max's narrative of trying to
overcome her trauma and complex feelings
about what happened to billy i am here
max to end your suffering once
and for all
thanks kate you're definitely bringing
in all the feels for this one
although sadie had a lot to work with in
regards to vecna's scare factor and the
highly detailed set there were still a
handful of moments where she essentially
had to react to nothing for example
vechna's vines which are a key component
in the scene weren't there at all none
of that was there so that was kind of
just like strain my arms and my neck to
make it look like there was something
wrapped around them there were also
quite a few wipeouts and intense stunts
that both sadie and her stunt double had
to perform there was like a rope tied to
my ankle and then dragged me across the
floor something else you might not know
is that during max's escape you know
when things are crashing down from the
sky none of that was there either so
sadie is bobbing and weaving and faking
it basically the entire scene took about
a week to shoot and it had a strenuous
rehearsal process sadie spent a lot of
time in the harness in preparation for
the cemetery levitation shot hey guys
[Applause]
four seasons in and the cast of stranger
things are definitely not strangers to
ridiculous onset antics so of course
we're taking a look at all the wholesome
content the cast gave us in season four
that's what it looks like underneath can
you believe that what a reveal
number one get your bets in now the race
is about to begin three two one and
they're off millie bobby brown starts
off with an early lead noah schnapp
seems to have developed a tummy ache
will he be able to recover in time to
beat millie no one can say for certain
but millie doesn't seem to be slowing
down in fact she's gaining speed and her
challenger is ducking out of the race is
this it for noah he's down and out
millie bobby brown is victorious
millie slayed at the fruit by the foot
challenge against noah schnapp who
gagged tough luck noah we wish you
better luck in the fruit roll-up
challenge number two did you hear millie
and noah made a pact to marry at 40 if
they aren't married already but they
would basically need to have separate
houses because hate to break it to you
they're just friends that doesn't stop
us from shipping them though maybe it
isn't too late for their characters
sorry finn the roller skating fail
between millie and noah is just clumsy
cute absolute ridiculousness on wheels
i just grabbed his boobs whoopsie daisy
number three finn took an arrow just not
to the knee
whoa
if that's a metaphor for marriage what
does it mean to take one to the head
we could watch this all day i didn't
realize it would be so big these are
honestly the kinds of stranger things
moments that we live for sorry could go
back that's so ridiculous
yes let's watch this part again
number four exterior shot sunrise
extreme close-up on quesadilla picture
this it's 5 30 in the morning after a
long night shoot you've fallen asleep in
your chair posied up beneath a thin
blanket for a 20-minute nap there's a
little bit of light in the horizon and i
open my eyes and caleb and gayton are
just sitting across from me staring
ahead eating a full-size like quesadilla
sadie sink just finds the idea of gayton
and caleb going to town on a quesadilla
at 5 30 in the morning absolutely
hilarious for no good reason why not
cereal or eggs no no 5 30 is quesadilla
time
number five that feel when your favorite
moment on set is also your least
favorite finn's favorite moment had to
do with one long shot filled with
complex choreography including swooping
ducking and sneaking we only had like
three chances at it the characters were
ambushed and all of the choreography was
complex as they attempted to escape the
house unscathed we gotta go we gotta go
right now the actors were utterly
exhausted by the end of this one shot
they went through all the hard stuff
play it had all gone perfectly at least
up until the very last guy a soldier's
supposed to come in and get shot and
then like shoot his gun up in the air
and that's it end of sequence and then
the camera whips to the door and the
soldier is not there so the director
calls cut and everybody's miserable is
no no it's coming everybody's collapsed
to the ground heavy breathing and then
suddenly boom a door gets kicked in
and the stunt guy's like
and he shoots his gun up in the air so
he goes through his whole thing and then
collapses to the ground but the worst
part and then he got up and he was like
i think that went well
number six smile you're on camera we
need to find out an outfit that i get
arrested in i've never thought i'd ever
have to say that sentence
there are a lot of things you never
anticipate saying in life but when you
take a job in the arts anything is
possible like blowing things up with
your mind
number seven we know you look completely
ridiculous out there but you've got to
keep it together millie perhaps millie
couldn't help from laughing because
she's hyper aware of the fact she looks
11 years old and bald and is dressed in
a hospital gown in the middle of a
parking lot reasons for why one would
find themselves in this situation maybe
she just signed herself out of the
hospital for a little day trip to the
local target because she can't stand the
taste of hospital food and needs some
waffles hey it's one theory not a good
one but it's a theory bro i hate eggos
number eight what do you call the ball
with feathers on the end sorry actors
don't know much about sports usually
sports are dangerous look at poor
charlie he's proof
and sports are even more dangerous if
you're an actor pretending to be good at
them that's going to be a long recovery
process there's a reason the drama geeks
and the athletes don't get along take it
from stranger things number nine it's
like video games but in real life
okay it's more like playing video games
with your annoying brother who likes to
make every sound effect himself boom
boom sound effects just aren't half as
effective as the real thing we must say
number 10 all work and no play makes the
cast dull dull children this is why we
had to share with you all the instances
of them dancing with questionable levels
of enthusiasm why do all the actors like
to film themselves dancing like fools
what was their motivation
number 11. they may be dancing fools but
gayten is the worm king just look at him
go the worm king could almost be season
five's villain hear that duffer brothers
pull a wanda vision and make it gayton
all along number 12. actors only need a
passable knowledge of most things when
you're a child actor you hardly need
that either you could say actors are the
biggest example of jack of all trades
master of practically nothing that feel
when your stunt double is way better at
roller skating than you sometimes life
just isn't fair but we bet noah schnapp
is making way more money for doing way
less of the dangerous stunts so the
joke's actually on talented people
number 13. you know what's worse than
socks with sandals socks with bowling
balls and the secret is only good if you
don't drop the ball then you're in
serious trouble he was probably just
trying to save a couple bucks on rental
shoes and who can blame him for trying
to snag a good deal perhaps he could
become a trendsetter number 14. yes this
season of stranger things seems to
include a lot of sport which means a lot
of dangerous sportsball activities like
having to learn to drive golf balls
charlie heaton and eduardo franco got
really good at it but ridiculously their
training did not come in handy well it
did but it didn't jonathan and argyle
were totally out of their minds during
that scene so it isn't like the golfing
needed to be good per se what was i
supposed to do not lie not lie yeah not
lie so hey free golfing trip
number 15. listen closely charlie
heaton's unlocked the secret to acting
you got this man just me and you in here
that's what acting is
serious acting thank you charlie we will
never forget your wisdom what we want to
know is who his acting partner is that
needs such wise wisdom the cameraman or
is it us if so we're flattered
number 16. caleb's imagining things
remember like this we didn't like with
that one thing and it smelled weird what
are you talking about i know
it was pretty funky guess it was just
caleb smelling it you remember it was
like no i don't remember what smelled
man and you know what they say whoever
smelt it dealt it however he who denied
it supplied it so gayten we're looking
at you
number 17 sometimes it's the little
things sometimes it's the micro things
there's the popsicle situation where
everyone found themselves way too
fascinated with a trail of ants it was
kind of a rough day i remember but the
ice pops made it like
on one incredibly long and stressful day
on set the cast was treated to a
delicious icy treat but the ants also
wanted a taste so gayton had this bright
idea that they could lead them away with
a trail of popsicle juice this theory
never got to be tested because somebody
sprayed the ants but the actors seemed
to be so fascinated by this situation
that sadie sync even got a photo this
leaves us with one question why just why
between that and the quesadillas sadie
finds the oddest things interesting
number eighteen time for a rewind back
to the best of season three millie bobby
brown and sadie sink really got to bond
during the filming of season three and
sometimes the wardrobe department does
their job and makes complementary colors
condiment each other ah meant to say
complement each other my name's ketchup
and my name is mustard together with
ketchup and mustard
ketchup and mustard the musical
coming to a theater near you no time
soon
and
not such good condiments on popcorn
which is why this musical's a flop
number 19. the paper towel part of this
sport isn't dangerous it's what comes
next we're not really sure what we just
saw when you cheat at paper towel ball
prepare to get slapped we guess is that
a rule or foul play we don't know but
the idea of a sport that is both soft
and gentle and good at cleaning up
spills that's also an aggressive contact
sport sounds just so
intriguing
number 20 when kids see things that look
like slides they're inclined to use them
as such
we don't think you're supposed to slide
down that seriously there are signs and
everything but you know what it saves a
ton of time so we know what we're doing
next time mall security be darned
stranger things season 4 has the best of
everything when it comes to 80s wardrobe
makeup and hairstyles as well as creepy
prosthetics this means thousands of
hours dedicated to the makeup chair that
we're taking a little peek behind the
scenes at number one even vecna's claw
is all practical effects vechna is 90
prosthetics jamie campbell bauer had to
have
2425 different appliances on him when
they initially tested the prosthetic it
took them roughly eight and a half hours
but they managed to whittle that down to
six so for a 7 am start time he would be
in the chair at 1am
every part of him was covered in some
way he had dentures over his teeth that
looked rotten and blackened he had
contact lenses and vecna's left hand was
also done with practical effects using a
metal framework the only thing that was
really done in post was his veins or
vines or whatever you want to call them
number two it takes effort to get that
no effort look eleven was going for hi
guys i'm getting ready to go to work i'm
just waiting on my
coffee
while it may not seem like jane sorry
11 puts much work into her outfits
behind the scenes is a whole other story
i think it takes about i'd say an hour
why is that the case when she barely
wears any makeup the most i have is a
bit of mascara and some blush well out
of all the young cast millie bobby brown
takes the longest a full hour to get
ready because of her wig yeah we need to
find out an outfit that i get arrested
in i've never thought i'd ever have to
say that
and millie and noah have way too much
energy for it being early in the morning
good morning
[Applause]
you know who doesn't seem like a morning
person who we bet finds this peppy
enthusiasm annoying joe kiri
number three you'd think if you were
possessed the last thing you'd see is
white the white contacts were no picnic
wearing them was described as being in a
bright white room all by yourself the
first time the actors put on the white
contacts the costume designer filmed
their experience to try and make it an
event and take the stress off their
inability to see properly oh maybe they
put contacts in you yeah were they
uncomfy yeah number four there isn't
enough money in the world somebody could
offer us to do this role
robert england played victor creel who
once in costume could neither speak nor
see
and his hands were bound to the chair he
could only communicate through yes or no
questions and nods it took him about two
hours in the makeup chair he just loved
telling the makeup artists who were huge
fans of his work as freddy krueger
stories he's incredibly comfortable with
all the materials after years of using
them so he knew what they were all for
he knew when to close his eyes and turn
his head and the makeup artists just
loved him number 5.
gayton's invented a whole new hairstyle
called hat hair supreme
headed up to my trailer looks like the
sun is still just rising so gate and
matarazzo definitely didn't have to
spend six hours in a chair i'm about to
go get ready put on my uniform
let's get it
gayton is sent home with some really
amazing skincare products
and i never use them and you might not
have known his hair is perfectly slicked
back under that hat and it looks
ridiculous we don't know that could be a
style you know like a horizontal mullet
situation business on top dustin takes
just slightly more time than finn he's
in the 20-25 minute range but if he has
a cap on which he usually does then it
takes even less time gayton's character
dustin has been starting to put more
effort into his looks too they're a
faucet spray yeah fair fast if you're
hoping to get steve's luscious long
locks you're out of luck the product is
no longer produced i should probably go
to work now
number six finn basically gets to roll
out of bed and right onto the set
hi finn has it easy compared to all the
actors who take ages getting prosthetics
on yeah it's i become mike in 20 minutes
it's about the time so i think you might
be the fastest right now well he's
competing for best time with another
member of the cast can you guess who
number seven david had a major
transformation from season three to four
then back to three again briefly david
must be the
now must be the the shortest okay but
he's covered in dirt and prosthetics he
doesn't have as much hair though this
season makeup makeup david was prepping
long before shooting began because he
had to trim down his dad bod to look
like the roughed up malnourished hopper
we see this season for flashback
purposes harbour had to get decked out
in prosthetics again because his face
just looked too thin harbor's pretty
comfortable with gaining and losing
weight for roles this is not even close
to the first time he's done it although
we bet putting on the weight is much
more fun
number eight
best wig award goes to joseph quinn
yes this was the wig and eddie munson
the character that we never knew we
needed out of stranger things number
nine then they placed it on his head and
he became dustin henderson a lot of
people don't realize that the hat was
never planned it was never meant to be
such a defining character trait we just
went to the fitting rooms one day and
then they had some baseball cap not just
skating all of the characters were
trying on hats and i put one on i was
like that's funny they did it for one
photo a goofy hat for one shot and it
just stuck the rest is history
number 10. do those suction cup things
actually stick or not
why is this so giant
i didn't realize it would be so big an
oversized arrow on your forehead all day
would get pretty annoying we bet
number 11. answer revealed finn is tied
with sadie for being such low
maintenance perhaps that's because
everyone but the sadie sink is decked
out in wigs and prosthetics and makeup
and she's still just the cool skater kid
who doesn't really care plus her natural
hair is gorgeous why would you cover
that up she only takes 20 minutes to get
ready too hair is typically 10 minutes
makeup is five minutes and that's
another five for costume it's seriously
just not fair to the others it's not
that bad we would guess noah would be
pretty quick too but alas the poor boy
is wigged he'd be more in the milly
department
number 12. the lost boy can be found
buried beneath dirt and sugar cornelius
made a small appearance but left a
lasting impression on all of us his
makeup was inspired by lost boys and one
small detail we appreciate is that they
put lip gloss on his lips to make it
look like he'd been eating sticky candy
the dirt is in the details
number 13. the return of daker means the
return of more ridiculous prosthetics
for him if the gooey prosthetics mess at
the end of the day is any indication of
how nasty the application process was
it had two equal early mornings and they
not only had to do all these prosthetics
on daker they also had to duplicate them
on his stunt double imagine having
double the work because the actors are
too valuable to break
number 14. we call this one road rash
chic we adore seeing a sleepy joe
pre-far a faucet wandering in to get his
day started
his road rash prosthetics were done by
autonomous fx the prosthetics look
disgusting if we do say so ourselves
good job team number 15. these wee beans
were all having fun the whole shoot it's
too bad their characters weren't it's no
secret that all of the patients in the
asylum look just a bit sickly and peter
ballard is no exception the goal was to
suck the life out of their skin and they
did that with a color correcting cream
intended to neutralize redness outside
of jamie campbell bower the patients
also got an added layer of wrinkle fx
makeup number 16 wigs are at least 30
percent of the personality of this show
look at my
wig
fabulous fit kara who plays karen
wheeler got to wear an awesome wig this
season the very vogue look of 1986.
it's cut with shorter layers on top to
show off that fabulous perm the look was
inspired by cape capshaw in indiana
jones and the temple of doom
number 17 would you cut your hair for a
roll grace had her hair cut for the role
of chrissy nothing over the top they
just trimmed it a bit shorter to give it
some beautiful volume she had it dyed
with highlights to match the topper wig
which are used to add volume to thin
hair number 18. sometimes simple is best
agent harmon the man who gets shot
trying to move the kids to safety had to
deal with a ton of blood the makeup
artist said this was a fun bloody mess
of a makeup we bet it wasn't too
difficult though less gutsy than some of
their other stuff daker we are looking
at you number 19 why does this one give
us scarecrow vibes it's the nose
definitely the nose
even without cgi this would make for a
fun halloween costume
number 20 we wish there were more shows
set in the 80s the aesthetic is just
perfect if you ask us it screams fun
something that is totally lacking in
this generation millie bobby brown is an
intense actor some may say she is even
going a bit method so she gets herself
into some painful situations for the
sake of her art ready to find out what
made her vomit or how about how she
navigated her broken knee
number one this is why actors sign
contracts that they won't engage in
dangerous activities i have
split my kneecap while this incident
didn't happen on the set of stranger
things it was still healing while millie
was filming and so she leaned on her
stunt double for support her double not
only had to do all of her stunts but
even some of the simpler tasks too like
riding a bicycle hey they should have
put her in the basket like they did with
e.t that was the inspiration for eleven
number two how did women used to wear
these all the time for anola homes
millie was wearing such a tight-laced
corset that it was painful for her and
she struggled with her fight scenes
fighting in a dress is never easy but
luckily the director had the forethought
to use the dress as a tool rather than
ignore its existence do not be deterred
from wearing a corset though you
actually have to do waste training to
get your waist used to the shape in
stages and if you think it's such an
outdated thing ear stretching is not all
that different of a concept but actors
generally don't have the time for waste
training and suffer through squishing
their organs instead number three this
scenario seems like it was totally
avoidable with a little forethought due
to the cold temperature that they were
filming stranger things and millie
struggled to do a scene in which she was
submerged in freezing cold water they
did try to heat the pool but it was just
too shallow to retain any heat did
anybody think about
maybe heating the air as well number
four while vacna may not be as spooky as
the smokey dude from the previous season
he was physically there on set jamie
campbell bauer messed millie up filming
stranger things his character was so far
from himself when he transformed from
henry into vechna that it freaked millie
out and made her cry bower said she was
terrified like literally terrified and
when she saw vacna she burst into tears
and she said that's not my friend i
don't know who this person is anymore
where's he gone was this acting jaime
was the one having a hard time getting
through the scene maybe millie just
messed him up number five the bullies
were a tad cliche but that doesn't take
away from millie's experience filming
the bullying for season 4 of stranger
things also mentally messed with millie
say that 5 times fast the scene at the
rinko mania where everyone is pointing
made her incredibly distressed and sad
it also hit noah schnapp really hard
having to just witness it and not be
able to help at all
number 6. did the duffers forget they
were working with children millie was
exhausted from overworking herself on
set long days not enough sleep and
mentally straining scenes led her to
collapsing into finn wolfhard's arms
weeping from sheer exhaustion the scene
actually made it into the show and you
can see in the shot finn break character
and look up for help luckily the panic
is as real as his character could have
mustered up we hope after that they let
the poor girl take a nap
number seven just the name of this stunt
sounds dangerous the corkscrew move
millie pulled in enola homes can get you
all twisted up if done wrong talk about
another knee injury waiting to happen
you can see in the movie how she does
get twisted up too number eight millie
is not a huge fan of any stunts done on
wires but one stranger thing stunt left
her so dizzy she vomited we had to do
like a rotation one once where i was
just constantly going upside down which
kind of sucked after spinning around and
around in circles take after take of
course she vomited number nine millie's
made of bricks just like the wall she's
being thrown against we swear for anola
millie was thrown up against a wall 15
times in a row she totally just brushes
it off but man does that look painful
number 10. the key to great acting is to
show up with your lines half memorized
millie said filming anola being drowned
was very safe she was in total control
but because of the quick loss of oxygen
she could only stick her head under for
about 15 seconds she went into the scene
with her lines memorized five minutes
before so she could give a genuine
performance of stumbling over her words
number eleven can somebody get her a t
or something millie lost her voice like
four times during the filming of
stranger things because she had to
scream so much then she lost her voice
again when she returned to the booth for
adr while this is all fine and well when
you're young you want to be careful
doing this stuff long term or there
could be serious repercussions number 12
the mind may know acting isn't real but
the body doesn't the reunion between 11
and cali was intense for millie not only
did it just make her weepy but she also
took her work home with her and it was
just so overwhelming fans are waiting
with breath it was baited for the final
episodes of stranger things and they are
literally chomping at the bit to know
all the behind the scenes secrets of the
show let's take a look of who's got the
spiciest info from the show at this
moment
there's a crew favorite
like any aspect of life there's just
going to be people that you favor more
and sure this might seem kind of mean
but hey let's be honest
most parents have a favorite child so
why wouldn't the crew have a favorite
cast member according to an interview
from the high chair in a case of answer
now a crew member sheepishly admitted
that millie bobby brown is definitely
the crew's favorite sorry to the rest
but the writing's on the wall now the
wall may be upside down but still
it's a tiring show while being an actor
seems to be a dog's breakfast of a
career with assistance fancy premieres
and all the craft table treats a tummy
could handle however the hours are most
definitely long so it makes sense that
people will be needing all the downtime
possible especially charlie heaton who
was notorious for napping it up all over
set from his trailer to just offset
we've got ourselves a sleepy guy
off script
sure the actors on set are younger than
your average cast but from noah schnapp
to millie bobby brown these are some
professionals to the core but they also
love to spill the hot goss and according
to these two in real life besties of all
the cast members who go off book all the
way finn wolfhard loves to mix it up
line wise and while there's a few scenes
that are improvised from being in on it
also known as when millie bobby brown's
character collapsed into finn's arms
from pure emotional exhaustion but
whatever the reason why finn loves the
off-script ways it's for sure working
breaking is the funnest part let's be
frank everyone loves a blooper reel
entire television shows have been based
around this concept and let's be honest
the post-credit blooper scenes of a
movie may be the whole reason to sit
through a movie and when it comes to who
on the cast was the ultimate in breaking
it could definitely be counted on gayton
matarazzo to bring in the funny and
co-star sadie sink can attest to gayton
being too too funny it's been getting
she had a tough time keeping it together
in whatever scene the two of them were
in together calling his style of comedy
genius here's hoping we get to see the
lighter side of gayton in his projects
to come an actor prepares
noah schnapp who portrays the sweet will
buyers from day one had intensely
emotional scenes and for the most
prestigious actor a day of high
intensity emotions is a challenge but a
way to get into it for those crying
scenes noah ironically enough turned to
movies a trick learned from fellow
co-star millie bobby brown when the
tears needed to flow noah watches the
sad scene from a favorite movie and it
gets the job done according to noah the
movie that does the trick these days is
the a24 critics fave everything
everywhere all at once
the breaker gets broken
and while we all now know that gate and
matarazzo is funny who's the one to make
the breakee break look no further than
caleb mclaughlin the actor who portrays
lucas sinclair has a laugh that can
break a thousand scenes and according to
gayton caleb has a laugh to make a stone
statue giggle oh so cute
music to make up to
fans truly cannot get enough of the
upside down vectna and all things
monster on stranger things the special
effects are award worthy and
spellbinding but what that actually
means for the actors is more time in the
makeup chair and long long hours of
makeup application can make the mind
wander especially if you're being
covered in prosthetics and literally
cannot move a muscle in these scenarios
it's good to have music on your side
according to lead makeup artist jamie
campbell bauer says that in tough times
of makeup application playing music
makes the day go better and from all the
music in the world to pass the time they
decide to pump marilyn manson to go hand
in hand with the monster theme the
beautiful people indeed
uber eats to the rescue
a big set secret is craft services is
usually the bomb actors and set guests
alike flock to enjoy the trees to break
up the long hours of shoot day and
fortunately actor noah schnapp had to
admit that the food onset is really just
okay therefore actors like noah tended
to make their own food and ubereats
ordered on the regular wonder what the
vechna's go-to order is
let's get rowdy
in a high chair interview with gayton
modorazo when asked what the tone of the
set was like the one and only word that
came to mind was rowdy and that can
definitely be felt with the tone and
chemistry of the set and gayton said his
character in season 2 got to spend all
his scenes with characters lucas and max
and come season 3 he will spend most
scenes with steve robin and priya so the
partying is apparent and i think i can
speak for all fans when i ask invite us
to the next jam please and thanks
one take tammy when it comes to
professionalism on set young actors do
not tend to have the best reputation
coming from the era of the low hands and
the lovatos reputations may precede
child actors before they even hit the
set however the stranger things cast is
breaking the mold once again by bringing
the seriousness and when it comes to
preparation being on point actor sadie
sink has confirmed that the actors who
could do a scene in one take award goes
to joe kiri who plays steve and gayton
matarazzo who portrays dustin henderson
according to sadie these two actors are
so prepared it's in and out of scenes
like a fiddler's elbow baby
now with a spiller fun fact about noah
schnapp this boy always needs a tied to
go stick constantly as someone who is a
self-identified spiller noah who has
been known to ruin a costume or two on
the first day of shooting a movie he
ended up spilling chocolate sauce all
along his back here's hoping laundry's
on set
maya hawk's fave scene
celebrity offspring maya hawk joined
stranger things in season three and
immediately became a fan favorite with
her portrayal of robin buckley but if
the people were wondering which scene
was a favorite to maya herself she had
the answer up and ready in season three
a sincere two-hander between robin and
steve at the video store that was shot
in one take was the scene of the moment
for her a chance for maya and jo kiri to
truly connect as actors is all she
really wanted and the audience and fans
were living for it it was perfect but
the shootout in one shot near the end of
season four there's a seminal shootout
scene
it was
crazy upon reading the script for that
scene director sean levy had a stroke of
creative inspiration that made him
realize to properly capture the essence
of this scene he wanted to shoot the
shootout in one shot and while movies
often employed this camera work think
the walk to the coppa in goodfellas
executing this kind of camera work in
the fast pace of a television show is a
great feat and props to director sean
levy because this scene had all the
feels and more
color matters costume designer of
stranger things amy parris has remarked
that the colors of the clothing really
matter with subtle hints to keep the
audience in keeping with the emotional
story they want to tell
it's also fun tying certain outfits
together with colors and pieces for
example the colors remained dark and
moody for scenes in russia and then they
pop hard when the pool days come so if
you're an audience member wondering why
they're feeling what they're feeling
look no further than color theory
wild rehearsal times
the cast and director executive producer
sean levy all could agree that the
shootout scene for the series was the
most intense
planning for a scene that will only be
shot in one take means everyone has to
be on their a-game all the time non-stop
and in terms of rehearsing the cast had
to be relentless
behind the scenes the cast was
choreographing and getting prepared to
do it all in one take therefore the cast
through and through all agreed that
prepping for that shot was the rehearsal
of all rehearsals
lucy hi
despite joining the show late sadisynk
has really been running up that hill to
become one of our favorite actors in
stranger things so we're taking a look
back at how she's grown over the course
of the show a lot of time spent in the
harness i guess number one growing up on
set you can expect a lot of your firsts
to happen there too sadie sings first
kiss happened on the show at the end of
season two she wasn't too keen on it so
the duffer brothers teased well now we
have to include a kiss truly they were
only teasing of course and sadie wasn't
perturbed saying she wouldn't have done
it if she didn't feel comfortable and
hey the nice thing about your first kiss
being with your friend is you'll never
cringe when you remember it like you
will if things didn't end so nicely with
your boyfriend i'm not mad at it
number two use the force max hitting
your head is a better option than facing
the wrath of max can we play this back
in slow motion maybe zoom in a little
this time beautiful
just
beautiful
number three we do not relish in the
thought of these characters ever growing
up you may recall the most terrifying
part of stranger things was the
condiment bottles my name's ketchup and
my name is mustang one thing's for sure
they're barbara cute together we catch
up and monster maybe they can get the
rest of the cast in on this how has
nobody asked the boys if they could be a
condiment which one they'd be who do you
think would play mayo finn noah and what
about hot sauce we think we'd leave that
to dager forget vacna the demogorgon
should have evolved into a hot dog for
season four's villain
number four and a hot dog demogorgon
would have been the perfect foil for
sadie sink who is a proud vegan she's an
animal lover through and through cast
your bets now is sadie sink a cat or a
dog person the answer is pretty apparent
she can be spotted playing with doggos
at every chance she gets and there are
oddly a lot of those chances on set this
is rocky she loves belly runs over her
last few years on the set sadie went
from being a vegetarian to fully vegan
this is sig it's short for sigourney and
she is a rescue dog
number five well vecna was definitely no
hot dog but the outfit was pretty real
sadie felt incredibly lucky to not have
to work with another cgi monster and
instead work with jamie campbell bower
in a mostly practical vechna prosthetic
which kind of you know made it easier
for me so i'm not like staring at a man
in a green suit
she spent somewhere between four days to
a week in the lair the shoot was intense
got a little scraped up but it was
really really fun it definitely wasn't
as intense as it was for jamie though
for a 7 am shoot he'd be in at 1am to
get his prosthetics on we bet he's
jealous of sadie with her quick change
in the morning
number six the change takes a little bit
longer than a broadway quick change but
in the grand scheme of film it's fast
max is one of the lower maintenance
characters it only takes sadie 20
minutes to get ready for the day so hair
makeup and costume she takes less
maintenance for a tv show than we take
getting ready for work in the morning
unless you're working from home then
showers and pants are optional as
opposed to her co-star millie who takes
an hour when she needs to get that wig
on those 40 minutes of beauty sleep
really make a difference
number seven that feel when you're
having a power nap because your 20
minutes of getting your costume on in
the morning are exhausting and the boys
just wreck it one of sadie's favorite
moments from season 4 was
incredibly odd it was 5 30 in the
morning and she'd fallen asleep in her
chair
she woke up to the sounds of birds
chirping and the sun just beginning to
rise and it was just beautiful
but then she opened her eyes and there
were gayton and caleb eating a giant
chicken quesadilla at 5 30 in the
morning and she just thought it was the
most hilarious thing
[Applause]
number eight she's rising on up in the
world season four brought in a new stunt
for sadie sync like this is the most
elaborate form of harness harness scene
that i've ever done
of course the episode was a show stopper
if you can get past a few of the
cheesier visual effects in becnus lair
sadie's performance was fantastic i
don't know how many i think it might
have been a week that we spent on that
or like four days i guess the simplicity
of her arc and the downplayed feelings
of the character were perfection it's no
wonder the world has become obsessed
with her this season but her levitating
stunt is probably the biggest stunt
she's ever got to do in her short career
she's growing up so fast hard to believe
she's already 20. they gave her
rehearsal time which we imagine they do
not give to the more seasoned actors to
simply float in the air for a few
seconds but there was a whole element of
choreography to it i can lean back a
little bit less
sort of
number nine the stranger things cast
actually spends more time apart than
together so sadie's pretty lucky she
gets to spend it with the funniest guy
in the cast it's been gaitin he's been
making me break character a lot recently
caleb also makes her crack up from time
to time but gayton takes the trophy for
season four sadie was also grateful that
the casts got shuffled around and some
unlikely pairings happened because it
meant she got to spend more time with
new people which she loves and she
really bonded with maya hawk who plays
robin is anybody else still stuck on
sadie's bemusement at the whole
quesadilla situation no just us okay
then
number 10 sometimes it really is the
little things that amuse dear sadie like
the 5 30 quesadilla popsicle day on the
set of season 4 was ridiculous as the
cast were enjoying a refreshing snack
the ants wanted to join them because you
had this idea we're like what if we made
a trail of popsicle juice did it work
who can say for sure somebody came over
and used some ant spray sadie thought
this was fascinating enough to capture a
photo of the first ad tudor holding out
the popsicle though yeah we can kind of
see why sadie's jealous of millie bobby
brown's social media game
number eleven imagine if your homework
was to do the one thing that scared the
pants off of you oh wait that sounds a
lot like school presentations well
sadie's homework was a bit different if
you recall she didn't join the cast
until season two of stranger things the
latest passenger to join us on our
curiosity voyage
maxine when it was already a massive hit
it's max and she was terrified to watch
the first season she hates horror movies
and had to keep turning down the volume
or covering her eyes she just couldn't
do it we wonder how she held up on set
was it all demystified or did she live
those darker moments in fear perhaps the
show is easier to watch now that she's
in it being fixated on her performance
might just be enough of a distraction
from those spooky scary things
number 12 we were a bit relieved when
the show brightened up in season three
as we imagined sadie was too the first
two seasons of stranger things were set
in the fall so the costumes were more
subdued and sadie's not a fall girl she
loves spring and summer fashion she
loves summer dresses she loves color so
she loved that they got to play with the
awesome 80s trends
boy is it
serious around here why does the cast
make stranger things season 4 look like
the most fun anyone's ever had roller
skating golf lessons ridiculous pranks
where do we sign up actually we're in
atlanta but we don't say that number one
this was one of the few times the cast
actually got to act off of monsters and
not stuff like tennis balls on a stick
the prosthetics were 90 real for vechna
the one thing added in post was pulsing
veins jamie campbell bauer's scene where
henry transforms into vechna was so
creepy
that it made millie cry bauer said i was
just fervently going through it and
building it and it was a lot i remember
doing it in the rehearsal and millie
just looking at me and saying something
like you're a freak but it gets worse
while henry transformed into vecna the
speech he gave brought millie to tears
she was so freaked out bauer admitted
she was terrified like literally
terrified and when she saw vecna she
burst into tears and she said that's not
my friend i don't know who this person
is anymore where's he gone bauer found
the moment incredibly challenging to not
break because of how shaken milly seemed
but freaking her out wasn't the only
thing going wrong with the prosthetics
bauer also struggled with finding the
voice for vechna he had a great voice
when he wasn't in the prosthetics but
the second he put them on it became
really hard to hear but in the end the
voice he's using is all him
number two sadie sync is a rising star
like this is the most elaborate form of
harness harnessing that i've ever done
sadie's levitating stunt rehearsal
happened to allow her to get comfortable
using wires a common courtesy we imagine
isn't gifted to most actors it must have
been pretty unsettling with those white
contacts in or are her eyes just rolled
into the back of her head
[Music]
number three after being mostly bald for
her young teen life millie decided
enough was enough millie bobby brown
refused to shave her head for the role
again so she spent an hour in the makeup
chair getting the wig applied as opposed
to finn wolfhard who takes 20 minutes
for hair and makeup and he's ready to go
it must be nice to be finn and just be
able to sleep in in the morning
number four can roller rinks please make
a serious comeback the roller skating
scene was some of the most fun millie
bobby brown and noah schnapp had while
filming season 4. they loved it so much
they spent their break skating too at
one point the two actors slammed into
each other and crashed to the floor
accidentally causing an awkward groping
situation but that didn't deter them
from getting back up and skating some
more
number five taking an arrow to the knee
was so 2011. an arrow to the forehead
however is much more appealing whoa
yes finn took an arrow to the head and
managed to live to tell the tale sorry
could we go back this is so ridiculous
every season of stranger things does
seem just a little more ridiculous than
the last doesn't it
number six need a hand there taker
getting taker montgomery's prosthetics
off at the end of the day was a sticky
mess is watching this making anybody
else nauseous it reminds us of the mind
flayer in eleven's leg
number seven and here we thought
contacts were supposed to help you see
better the designer had all the actors
do videos their first time trying out
the new white contact lenses just to
take the pressure off and add a little
fun to the experience because the lenses
were pretty trippy to wear oh maybe they
put contacts on you yeah were they
uncomfy yeah
number eight the costumes just keep
getting better with every season
and this season they're just epic how
are they going to top this for the next
one yeah we need to find out an outfit
that i get arrested in did you know
there could be up to five eddie munson's
filming at one time that's a nightmare
for the costume department who would
have to source five identical costumes
do you know how hard that is to do when
you're thrift shopping the kids dungeons
and dragons shirts were based on real
ones from the 1980s and were made by a
designer who actually plays the game
costume designer amy paris said the
duffer brothers were very specific about
wanting it to look handmade like it was
made by the kids and just a fun fact for
you when actors are running barefoot
it's actually up to the costume
department to find them nude shoes
number nine we only wish our jobs
required this kind of training huh
charlie heaton and eduardo franco had to
learn how to play golf for the show they
were whacking golf balls at an empty lot
in the desert eduardo admitted neither
of us had ever played golf so they took
them to a country club and they had to
dress the part eduardo went on to have a
crazy day of learning how to drive a
golf ball while he sipped on sodas and
charlie sipped on beer he found it oh so
satisfying to hear the ball pop when he
whacked it right but the irony of
learning to do it all right was that the
characters had to in eduardo's words
play the sport pathetically
number 10 free golfing shooting hoops
we're actually jealous of all the fun
they're having looks like for caleb
mclaughlin filming the basketball scenes
were a ton of fun and he's actually got
some pretty sick moves also that number
8 jersey he's sporting is in honor of
kobe bryant
number 11. this genuinely sounds like
torture how did christopher get through
this sleeping christopher strand had his
eyes and mouth completely covered with
prosthetics and his hands tied to his
easy chair for the roll this meant he
couldn't see and he couldn't speak he
couldn't see he couldn't speak and he
could barely move in order to
accommodate him the best they could the
crew could only ask him yes or no
questions so he could only communicate
with a slight nod or shake of the head
number 12
seriously now they're having freaking
water balloon fights what is this work
or play
children all of them yes we're feeling
an extreme case of fomo noah schnapp is
quite the prankster on set which is why
the entire cast and crew took it upon
themselves to seek revenge yes they
ruthlessly pummeled him with water
balloons
number 13. teenagers are destructive
little devils the most dangerous game of
pinata happened on set straight out of a
wrestling match came noah dealing the
final blow with a chair
number 14. this sounds like a good name
for a band
the scene where 11 was being bullied and
had a milkshake tossed on her was super
taxing on millie it put her in a super
sour mood she recalls 50 people there
laughing and pointing at her and the
bullying was so much she admitted i
remember feeling super distressed and
really sad she wasn't the only one
feeling sad either her co-star noah
schnapp also cried when he wasn't
supposed to milly said to him i don't
know if anyone knows that but you
actually got really upset do you
remember that you weren't meant to cry
in the scene you just got naturally
really emotional because it was actually
quite distressing to watch you've got
your good days and you've got your bad
days we guess that's what makes tv
dramatic number 15. we don't need any
old excuse to eat a fruit by the foot on
set millie absolutely obliterated noah
schnapp in the fruit by the foot
challenge noah gagged and gave up but
millie was seeing this competition
through to the end no using no hands you
have to eat it as fast as you can it
seems like everything on set is upside
down from what we're seeing on tv with
plenty of pranks games and goofing off
it's no wonder these kids would rather
be filming than in high school if you
could be part of any of these moments
this season which would you have picked
let us know in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things